[Music]
tifany asks why are you such a fan of
lap dances okay in 2007 all right there
was a movie called grindhouse and in the
trailer Quentin Tarantino himself
promised us a lap dance so I went to see
that movie on 10 hours and 47 minutes of
it and there was no lap dance anyway so
then flash-forward I get the DVD with my
buddy and we watched the six hour
director's cut and lo and behold there's
the lap dance that we've been promised
in the original trailer but made me
wonder how many other movies has that
happened in where they film a lap dance
and they just cut it before it ends up
you know hitting the theaters I've
gotten really good spotting those
moments where it's obvious they filmed
one and just didn't make the final cut
so I point about us since why don't you
stop doing the conversation videos and
other books and just do more sins videos
all right well I'm gonna assume just by
asking that you've never made a sins
video but whatever let's forget for a
second that most people who watch the
conversation videos actually enjoy them
let's throw that aside what you're
talking about is a time difference it
takes way longer to make a sense video
than it does to make a conversation
video so comparing the Grand Canyon to
your vagina
it's like saying sure to cook myself
some dinner or should I build a log
cabin with my bare hands from scratch
doing a conversation video in no way
keeps us from doing the sins video it
keeps us from doing a second sins videos
that they take forever I mean it's time
we're happy to spend weekly but you know
maybe just watch the sins videos once a
week and go about your life there's this
new tool YouTube just put out actually
that it's called not watching videos
that you don't like you should check it
out
all right how many people are there
behind cinemasins okay
this one I'm glad we can clear out
cinemasins is two people but not right
now not me you and I it's like you and I
should be considered like one entity
right along with any other us 'as you
see running around here right like the
other guy has never been on camera but
he's been part of the writing and
shooting and editing since the beginning
of cinemasins just like teller well I
mean teller appears on camera just
silent well not exactly
it's a fine analogy all right everybody
knew what I meant all right there's
another guy and he's mysterious
how's he mysterious in ways will you
have sex with me well I don't know you
but sure wait is she hot send a picture
it's just an email
we know it's a girl to take my chances